you
I thought I'd start
just reminding you that this talk
combines work in two books one of them
went on the Left called the four steps
to the Epiphany the other one a book
that you know if you don't have on your
shelf you should it's called business
model generation from a guy named
Alexander Osterwalder and if you're an
entrepreneur the book on the right is
almost now a fundamental text and I say
text even though most people now have
Kindles I think there's probably a a
good startup to be had to make fake
spines for all the books you now have on
your Kindle because there's no way to
tell that when you graduate from
Stanford what do you actually have read
so I if anybody's looking for an idea
for a startup that's a joke so I guess
in this this class I'll have to tell you
when to laugh so I will
so I also write a blog anybody ever see
it's called Steve Blank calm how many of
you are entrepreneurs or we want to be
so every possible way to screw up a
startup is in here most of them done by
me so if you want some stories on how it
was to actually build some companies and
then you know in the blog I kind of
expanded some thoughts about
entrepreneurship since I first wrote the
text four steps to the Epiphany
so I want to tell a few short stories
today the first one and observation
about the democratization of
entrepreneurship I've been in Silicon
Valley now for 33 years hard to actually
remember back that far even harder to
admit but in the last 33 years
entrepreneurship and its twin venture
capital has changed dramatically but
subtly though I don't think we've even
understood how dramatic those changes
are and I thought I'd spend the first
part of this talk actually going through
those changes and then talking about one
of the techniques in one of the pieces
in entrepreneurial education that's been
one of the catalysts of change so I just
want to remind you
what some of the constraints are for
startups when entrepreneurs first came
to this valley 60s 70s 80s and even the
1990s it cost a lot of money to start a
company how many of you were in software
startups you know hopefully a good
number of you in software
started with your credit card but in the
old days if you were in a software
business step one was by extensive
workstations step two was by expensive
development tools it cost millions of
dollars even for a software company to
get started
pre turn of the century some of this is
still true in Hardware domains but it
was also just an implicit fact of every
type of startup it cost millions to
start a company to is it took a long
time to get the first customership
engineering was done using something
called waterfall development I would
spec the product make sure it had an
entirely long and perfect list of
features making sure that I got that
feature list by looking at all the
competitors features making sure mine
was at least three or four longer
handing that list to engineering who
would go off and go implement for
something called version one sometime
months more than likely a year or two
from the day you started this waterfall
development methodology was about all we
knew until the 1990s customers took a
long time to adopt first customers in
Silicon Valley were government
subcontractors they did not buy in days
or weeks it took
months if not years to get an order the
next wave of customers in Silicon Valley
were companies again these were long
sales cycles and the number of customers
for Silicon Valley companies could have
been measured in hundreds maybe
thousands high startup failure rate for
40 years the implicit notion was that
startups or smaller versions of large
companies and that all you did in a
start-up in your board meeting reporting
to your board was focus on your
execution of the business plan that your
VCS had bought into here's what we're
supposed to do here's when we were
supposed to ship here's the orders that
were supposed to get here's the revenue
we're supposed to have and by the way
there were a limited number of these VCS
3,000 santel Road there's maybe 20 of
them up to about 1975 that was it they
all wore white shoes who looked like
they just came off the boat and a nice
pressed pants all went to the same
school very small ecosystem and not only
was the 3,000 Santo Road it was limited
to a few regions 3,000 Sand Hill Road
Menlo Park California he wanted money
that was the address so what's happened
what's happening there's something kind
of interesting these were all
constraints on eliminating the number of
startups certainly in Silicon Valley
I'll observe in the last five years
almost all of these constraints
certainly for the wave of Internet
commerce and social networking companies
we've seen have been eliminated
all at once let me tell you why startup
constraints have been replaced by what I
call an entrepreneurial explosion now
the cost of getting to a first product
can be developed if you're doing a
software company on inexpensive PCs
Mack's using open-source software the
cost of starting a company is no longer
measured in millions its measured in
your credit-card limit a short time for
first product it no longer takes years
to develop a product using an agile
development methodology that is a
software methodology that allows you to
develop incrementally and iteratively
now says you could get a Minimum Viable
Product or a core part of your product
out the door in weeks if not months or
months of not weeks fast customer
adoption our customers are no longer
only the government in corporate Silicon
Valley has now turned to consumer
applications whoever thought Facebook
would have had a half a billion
customers that would have been science
fiction science fiction think about a
Silicon Valley company with a half a
billion customers in how many years
three four unbelievable lore start a
failure rate startups until the last
five or ten years have been in hit or
miss proposition when we talked about
the people we talked about having great
board members but we really didn't
understand the first line big insight in
the last couple of years is no startups
are not smaller versions of large
companies probably if you take away
anything from this talk that's it
everything you learn how many of you
were in Stanford GSB and then Business
School great everything you learn in the
business school about large company
management is destructive for an
early-stage venture big idea it's not
kind of useful or GL just change it what
you'll hear later and I'll explain why
its destructive good news is in the
entrepreneurial group at GSB we teach
the right things about early-stage
ventures but they are not
interchangeable and you'll hear me say
this
out this talk large corporations execute
existing business models startups search
for them the tools needed techniques
needed but people needed for execution
versus search is what we now know to be
radically different understanding those
rules that's what the rest of this talk
will be about but let me just finish the
circle we now have a much larger pool of
risk capital just in Silicon Valley I
couldn't even put all the names on here
there's been an explosion in the last
twenty years and even more so in the
last five or ten of the pool of
available capital seed rounds super
angels larger pools of venture capital
all kind of exploded and we're venture
capital and entrepreneurship was limited
to technology clusters like Silicon
Valley we can now easily say just as
easy to start a company this in minimal
Park as it is in San Francisco New York
Shanghai Israel Chile Singapore Finland
etc while still the highest
concentration of technology innovation
in the u.s. is here because basically
we're a company town meaning our cluster
does nothing but this now there are
other clusters that are forming in
multiple cities so this talk is going to
be about one of those pieces of the
explosion about what we now know about
how to lower startup failure rate and
that's the purpose of the time the next
story about that starts with this notion
that not all startups are equal now I've
been in Silicon Valley for more decades
than I care to remember
or are actually possible to remember by
now but one of the things that surprised
me teaching at Stanford was going into a
classroom of some other professor and
hearing them talk about entrepreneurs
and who an entrepreneur was and with the
shock of me we're not recognizing who
they were describing because it turns
out if you get three professors in the
room to try to define startups and
entrepreneurship
you'll get nine definitions including I
throw four of them in myself it dawned
on me that we really lacked a common
language of who's an entrepreneur
what's a startup even more important now
that our government has decided to get
involved with entrepreneur
entrepreneurship and startups in fact I
tend to panic hearing that the Labor
Department is going to have an
Occupational code for entrepreneurs we
should all like figure that that it's
about the time the entrepreneurship has
jumped the shark but I want to give you
my definition of the types of
entrepreneurs there are you know there
are small businesses in the United
States that are entrepreneurial my
parents came to the United States as
immigrants in steerage bottom of a boat
passed under Statue of Liberty came
through Ellis Island lived in a Lower
East Side of New York and their dream
was to open their own grocery store that
was their dream American dream be
self-employed not working the garment
district you know be able to do what
they wanted to do ten years later they
managed to scrimp and save enough money
that they did and their job was to serve
known customers with a known product and
feed the family and their exit criteria
for them being a start-up was they were
finding a business model their business
model consisted of understanding the
types of foods their customers wanted
stocking them and figuring out how to
price it and they did it with an
existing team my mother and father and
then when we were old enough to see over
the pickle barrel it was us and if they
made a million dollars in their entire
lifetime would have been a lot of money
but I believed and still believed that
my parents were entrepreneurs and they
did do a start-up but their goals were
very different from what we consider
startups in Silicon Valley
their goal of a start-up was to be
self-employed not have anybody tell them
what to do and they did not wake up in
the morning thinking they were gonna
take over the grocery business in the
United States their vision was limited
and they were happy to be limited but at
the same time there was no way they were
gonna able to go to a venture capitalist
even if one existed at the time and
raised money money came from bank loans
friends and family whatever they could
save at a profit so I just want to
observe that small business startups are
the still the core of what America does
there are 5.7 million small businesses
in the United States today
it's ninety-nine point seven percent of
all registered companies it employs 50%
of all non-governmental workers are in
small business startups now what's funny
in Silicon Valley we have a term for
these people we call them lifestyle
businesses their lifestyle some of you
were yeah your lifestyle business all
right they could be people who are
consultants people who run their own you
know grocery store hairdresser
carpenters plumbers small groups of
prompt plumbers their lifestyle business
you know what the real name for these
people are normal those of you sitting
in this room are the ones who are crazy
because what these people want to do is
like live a life and then you know go
out if they have some spare time
actually enjoy it
they did it their goal is not to work
24/7 though most of them or some of them
get trapped in doing that but their goal
is not to take over the universe or
anything else but they are entrepreneurs
I will observe that there's another
group of entrepreneurs and startups and
we also if were smaller for Silicon
Valley entrepreneurs we tend to diss
these people - its entrepreneurship and
large corporations fifteen years ago a
professor at Harvard named Clayton
Christensen really nailed this
definition Christensen said look the
two types of innovation in a large
corporation one is sustaining innovation
that is large companies start with a
core product and as they mature they
start spinning out innovations around
that core new features different pricing
add-ons supplementary products and large
companies as a whole tend to be good at
this
sustaining innovation deals with
existing markets and known customers
with no one product features but large
companies have a finite life because of
things that happen mostly out of their
control
competitors emerge new technologies show
up customer tastes change legislative or
legal changes all of a sudden large
companies are faced with disruptive
innovation and disruptive innovation
requires them to come up with new
products new technology deal with new
customers new markets and new channels
best example closest to home is Google
world's leader in search they were going
to own the planet forever until the
somebody raised the pirate flag in Palo
Alto bunch of guys called Facebook holy
Camp Google which was a the world's
leader and your interaction with the
browser literally in a span of three
years found a competitor growing up in a
domain which they had absolutely no
expertise Google is facing disruptive
innovation and will do anything they
need to do because they're smart and
innovative company including acquire IP
technology product companies etc so go
deal with this threat but I just want to
point out that inside of large companies
there are groups that are equivalent to
startups today who are searching for a
business model not executing one and
then finally by the way the way you deal
with
disruptive innovation in a large company
is one you try to build it
that is oh great there's Facebook will
build Facebook inside look how big we
are we could do that and I don't know if
any of you ever wondered but I always
wondered how come
large companies get liked ripped by the
underwear at their ankles you know every
time they try to compete what you know
they've got like a gazillion resources
how come they can't compete with scrappy
little startups and the answer is
Shakespearean and it's tragedy and we'll
be talking about this in the in the rest
of the talk
large companies once they get to a
certain size hire people to execute
known business models they manage those
people on profitability and success in
executing the model they were hired for
large corporations don't hire
generically innovative people and I
don't mean they don't have innovative
people I'll give you an example
McDonald's have I ever been and want
everyone to admit ever walking into a
McDonald's okay good right McDonald's in
Des Moines Iowa and McDonald's in Menlo
Park California believe it or not have
essentially the same menu imagine one
day the Menlo Park McDonald's hires an
out-of-work entrepreneur as the manager
by accidents gonna happen one day who
wakes up and says this menus boring you
know we ought to be serving pizza next
morning is a line almost rioting outside
the McDonald's because you can't get
your Big Mac anymore point is McDonald's
doesn't want innovators in the majority
of its execution chain somewhere back in
Illinois I'm sure they have a lab of
testing innovative ideas but ninety-nine
point seven percent of employees in a
large corporation are hired to execute
an existing business model which makes
trying to do disruptive innovation
internally 10 X or a hundred X harder
not cuz people are stupid in large
corporations far
but they were actually hired to go do
one thing and they're in sentences it
would do one thing and here are these
crazy people in the offices next door to
them trying to say we're not filling out
the expense reports in triplicate weird
entrepreneurs just culture clash all the
time so large companies tend to acquire
not always but often they acquire
intellectual property they might require
to acquire talent headcount which is by
the way why Google acquired 50 companies
last year most of it for people they
acquire product lines or they acquire
for customers or they inquire for entire
businesses and pnls various reasons why
companies acquire so I just want to
point out so far we have two types of in
of innovators two types of startups
small business large companies but
that's not what Silicon Valley is about
Silicon Valley is about this a third
group which I call not startups but
scalable startups just for the sake of
making the point that when you do a
start-up in Silicon Valley it is not I
want to grow from one to five people
it's I want to do something subjective I
want to change something I want to build
something important and typically the
goal is to solve for unknown customers
and unknown features and you start as a
start-up on the left but your goal is to
find a business model and grow into a
large market and to grow into a large
company startups search for a repeatable
and scalable business model your goal is
to go from the box on the left to be a
box on the right a company that could
execute a scalable startup is designed
to grow big and what differentiates it
as well from a small business and a
large corporation is it typically needs
risk capital venture capital by the way
Amy I know what venture capital used to
be called in the 1950s when they came up
with
name they said oh yeah why don't we call
it adventure capital and the bankers in
New York said you know yeah they said
okay well shorten it
so it's venture capital but when Silicon
Valley says startup what we're really
talking about is not small business
startups and not large corporation
startups this is make sense why it's
really important is as we sit here in
Silicon Valley we all think we kind of
know what the word means you step out at
this bubble go to Washington DC try to
talk to legislators or the executive
branch go to Sacramento go to Nebraska
people have no idea of what this is they
know what small business
entrepreneurship is making sure we use
the right words and also as an educator
making sure we educate correctly outside
of the United States this is the unknown
outside the US small business
entrepreneurship that's what people
think entrepreneurs do so here's my
definition of what a Silicon Valley
startup is which by the way just helped
me understand what is it and we're
supposed to be doing my definition is
that a start-up is a temporary
organization used to search for a
scalable and repeatable business model
that's a big mouthful but pretty
important one is a temporary
organization my belief there's no such
thing as a 12 year old startup there's a
two year old start-up attached to a 10
year old failure big idea because your
job and a start-up is to search if he
knew exactly how to execute you just
would hire the first hundred and 50
people as quick as you can
you actually are looking for something
and what you're looking for is a
repeatable and scalable business model
the words repeatable and scalable should
make sense but the word business model I
will also define as we get further into
this talk makes sense so far
so by the way if any you've been in
startups yeah so there's a secret memo
none of you have ever gotten have you
venture capitalist and no one's gonna
admit it okay there's a secret VC memo
because instead of this diagram you go
from stirred up to large company feces
actually no it doesn't work like that
you go from startup to transition to
large company
I always thought gee okay I get it
I leave being a start-up when I find the
scalable repeatable business model and
when I do that my expectation was at the
board meeting at a minimum they were
gonna pin a medal on my shirt give me a
handshake maybe a gold watch and parade
me you know up and down the aisles of
the company with you know throwing
confetti saying congratulations instead
you know what happens to most
entrepreneurs when they when they
find the scalable repeatable model board
meeting kind of goes like this the VCS
for the first time first time feces who
didn't even know your name are now
paying attention to you I don't know if
all you know but a typical Silicon
Valley VC sits on anywhere from eight to
twelve boards
alright so when they're showing up at
your board meeting they physically have
to get out their Blackberry or Android
phone or iPhone and look up your name
right then they're looking at the sign
on the building to figure out there at
the right company alright you see one VC
they see 12 CEOs in a month and by the
way when you're talking about your board
meeting blah blah blah blah blah
searching blah blah blah you know what
they're kind of listening they but they
might be on their phone but the board
meeting when you say and we think we fat
cracked the code and we have some
repeatable revenue or users or something
all of a sudden you got that VCS
attention because for the first time
you're no longer a faceless mass in his
portfolio but all of a sudden you are in
an important company that might actually
provide a substantive return in that VCS
portfolio
all of a sudden the VC is now looking at
you in a way that's making you kind of
uncomfortable because they're looking at
you up and down and through the side and
what they're actually thinking is okay
you got me out of the box on the left
but are you the person capable of taking
me to the Box on the right you did great
flying around the country you did great
you know doing one thing on Tuesday and
the next on Wednesday and something
different and hiring and firing or
whatever but gee you've just told me we
no longer need to do that what you've
just told me is we've gone from search
where we're doing different things every
day to repeatable where we need to
execute now my question is is the vc is
are you the guy or the woman interesting
question so there's really a box in the
middle called the transition and what
the V sees don't tell you is you're
going from search to build to execute
and what happens in this build phase is
most often than not the founders depart
and that's a very polite way of saying
you're holding on to the door frame and
the VCS they're pushing you out because
most first-time or even second or third
time founding CEOs don't quite
understand it's not personal
but right here your interest and your
VC's interest which were aligned have
now diverged because VCS have a
different business model than you and
their career objective is different than
you it isn't personal
it's business and the business part is
what venture capitalists want to see is
somebody capable of bringing in scale
that is growing your startup to a large
company are you is the founder capable
of doing that and more often than not
they bring in what's pejoratively called
the suit but truly is an operator
somebody who's an operating executive
who is actually skilled
at doing this makes sense so far anybody
ever encountered this this is why secret
memo you never get and it's nothing
personal but bad news is and I laugh
about this with my friends who were VCS
how come we don't tell founders this and
make us deep so imagine I'd be the only
VC telling you hey by the way when you
succeed I'm going to replace you do you
think I'd ever get another deal and so
this is kind of the dirty secret and it
actually does a injustice to
entrepreneurs not understanding this is
a normal part of the process the the
interesting conundrum is think about who
runs today the most successful
technology companies in the world their
original founders Steve Jobs Larry
Ellison Jeff Bezos at least for the
first couple of decades Bill Gates
I'll contend they're the exceptions that
prove the rule they actually and by the
way remember jobs had to get fired by an
operating executive he brought in to go
understand this there's a growth process
that most founders don't actually go
through fast enough world-class founders
actually figure out how to quickly
almost like a chameleon adapt and learn
a set of skills that most of us take
multiple companies to go do by the way
anybody know how many Presidents Bill
Gates went through with Microsoft I
think at least five and he learned from
every one of them from every one of them
makes sense just keep that in mind by
the way as an aside as I said you fail
if you stay a start-up so one of the
things I thought I'd share is my
startups aren't small versions of a
large company and this really is an
interesting thing to process because
when I started in Silicon Valley I said
oh yeah I know what we do we do
everything that we used to do in our
large company we'll do here in our
startup so all six yes that that's very
different I'll suggest that's wrong that
in a start-up the Box on the Left we're
searching for a business model and it
needs to be found by the founders
now we're looking for product market fit
and we're looking for a repeatable sales
model and finally when we actually exit
the startup phase we could start hiring
managers but in a large company you're
executing and you become a large company
when you kind of hit cash flow breakeven
and you're profitable and you're hitting
rapid scale and you're hiring new senior
management has something called Dunbar's
rule that 150 people that's another
major organizational shift if I know why
a hundred and fifty people become a
company they're no Dunbar's rule yeah it
turns out that human beings can't
remember more than 150 people it's not
exactly that number but plus or minus
you're just as a human being we're
hardwired for that number
you've become a company and when you
become a company your drive for a profit
of ability is hiring people who know how
to do the same thing because you've
already figured out what that successful
model is let me give you another
difference large corporations run on
balance sheets cash flows and income
statements anybody in the GSB taking the
accounting class and the required
classes right if you're running the
company and you don't know how to do
corporate accounting you're gonna put
put the company out of business I don't
care what department you're in you need
to know that it's the very basis of how
we manage and grow companies anybody
ever been in a startup board meeting for
now I got to tell you I was in start up
yet board meetings for eight startups 20
years first board me all right what do
we do what do we do is we show them
balance sheet income statement cash flow
okay great what's the income statement
say month zero month one zero
what's the same month two zero one three
zero but not only am i paying somebody
to prepare all these documents we
actually think that where the board is
actually managing something by looking
at these numbers here on the left
I'll content from now on if any board
does that in the startup you walk out
the room the only thing you need to know
about numbers in a start-up in the early
days they want that it has to do with
dollars is how much cash do you have
left and what rate are you burning it at
until you hit the ground there are other
numbers you need to know which are much
more important that you want your board
engaged with and that's the metrics
associated with you trying to search for
a business model here happens to be some
for an internet startup your own will be
different but the key idea is you want
your board engaged in helping you figure
out what numbers should we be looking at
they ain't accounting numbers you should
be so lucky to have this problem as how
to count the amount of cash we have or
the amount of money that's coming in the
door and maybe you're the rare startup
David actually needs to do that on day
one most startups are trying to find a
business model and you really want your
board engaged in a much different
conversation are we looking at the right
metrics or are we going after the right
people should we be measuring something
else makes sense sales you may ever see
a large corporate VP of Sales not a
large but I mean Oh VP of Sales for a
large corporation anybody ever see one
okay what do they look like
how tall are they yeah six feet or more
what cars their hair Scott right a
little bit of gray and what's their golf
handicap single digits large corporation
VP of Sales and we laugh about that
those are actually good skills to have
those are actually good characteristics
to have they're also not stupid they're
actually pretty smart but they almost
look in the United States like a type
because there are world-class at
building sales organizations making
those organizations scalable and having
sales forces that could sell off our
price lists and data sheets and they
operate brilliantly to an existing
revenue plan that's what a world-class
VP of Sales does and when you do a
start-up my dream was always hey I'll
just hire one of those people if I can't
get on one of those people I'll hire one
of their directors and tell them they
could be a VP in my startup and that was
always the fairy hey look they did great
over there I have to tell you my last
startup
I hired a world-class VP of Sales early
from Oracle and I still remember the day
we just got thrown out of like our
fourth company we called on in a row
it's pouring rain kind of like a day
like this but worse and like you know
I'm shell-shocked does the founder but I
got this great VP of Sales and he's
driving a nice if you have to start the
car and I go where are we going he said
well we got another call I said Jay
another call with this guy thrown out
four times in a row
I said don't we want to stop and think
about like what we learned he said Steve
great salespeople just never take no you
know they just keep going and by the way
that's correct only when you actually
understand unknown model when you don't
know what the model is that's
destructive behavior and in fact those
people world-class salespeople actually
melt down in startups because this guy
in our next week started freaking out
when I said while this presentation
isn't working I'm gonna make up a new
one and that was making it up on the
drive to the customer that was you can't
do that I know what the existing pitch
is Jay the existing pitch isn't working
well yes but that's the one we have well
I'm the founder we can make up a new one
smoke would come out of his ears and it
wasn't because he was dumb it was
actually because he was great at what we
had hired him for and it was our job our
mistake for not understanding the
following titles on the right actually
don't mean the same thing on the left
I'm sorry
I'm not I'm not sure I can but I will
try titles VP of Sales VP of Marketing
VP of is deaf well understood in a
company that's executed G VP of Sales
and a large corporation hire the
Salesforce make the revenue plan hey you
know execute the model sell off the
datasheet and price list right that's
what a VP is it would take whatever spec
you want in a large corporation that's
pretty close in a start-up in the first
year or two that's not what the job is
oh my god what is the job well I don't
know we're gonna go get out of the
building and figure it out until we like
datasheet
price list website we're going to change
them until we get them right if you
don't have people capable of operating
in chaos on the left it explains why
most of these people meltdown when they
hit a start-up because even though we
use the same title the job descriptions
if we're honest are actually quite
different does that make sense now I'm
engineering the same thing large
corporation great VP of engineering
could take a market requirements
document put it together in a waterfall
development plan hire engineers and then
at the end have a QA and tech pops
department I could always now tell when
a start-up is in trouble because the
first thing I ask is in the first year
or two so how many people you have in QA
and tech pubs and if the answer is like
more than one it's a disaster because in
a startup in almost every case you need
to be doing a very different type of
engineering waterfall development in a
large company says I spec the product
and I execute and you'll get it at the
end in a startup and except for corner
cases you really don't know what to spec
and what you want to do is agile
development incremental and iterative
development that requires much different
engineering leadership and talent
so we'll talk a little bit later about
the types of startups there is a type of
startup that's executing in an existing
market an existing market by my
definition simply says you have a
product which is substantively better as
agreed to by the existing customers in
that market and you are going to take
market share from the incumbent if
that's the product you have then you
could spec the entire product on day one
that's the corner case in most any other
type of startup that's not the case
you're searching for right what the
right feature set should be does that
make sense
and in fact it's a detailed than the
book four steps to the Epiphany I'm not
trying to flog the book but just FYI
agile development continuous deployment
continuous learning self-organizing
teams and you're going to ship not the
maximum feature set which is the goal in
a large company but the minimum feature
set or sometimes called the Minimum
Viable Product big idea in a start-up
you want to get to market as quick as
possible but not by offering every
possible feature but doing the exact
opposite what that's really a hard
concept I want to offer the minimum
features on day one who ever thought you
could offer a smartphone without copy
and paste remember which smartphone that
was iPhone or who could ever offer a
music player without an FM tuner anybody
remember what that device was iPod right
minimum feature set right will
incrementally add features later as
needed but first we want to get the
product out and see if our core idea is
correct last piece especially for those
of you in business school large
corporations love business plans
business plans are wonderful in a large
corporation I know who the customers are
I knew who the market is I'm doing a
product line extension I could spec
everything and it describes a set of
knowns a business plan in a startup
is a creative writing exercise a
business plan and a start in a
university I will content is only done
because it's easy to grade not because
it provides students any use at all it's
actually detrimental to your career in a
start-up instead of a business plan you
want to spend your time working on a
business model and I will describe later
what a business model is but it
describes unknowns and set you up for
what you have to learn so as an aside
how to startup search for a business
model well the search is something
called customer development here I've
blown up that box of startup and the
implementation is called agile
development and I'm going to talk a
little bit more about customer
development after 40 years I think we
understand why startups fail because
more startups fail from a lack of
customers than from a failure product
development now this is a mind-blower in
Silicon Valley and this goes across any
technology except for biotech leave
biotech aside but hardware software
silicon we take more technology risk
here in Silicon Valley and score per
square foot than the other place in the
world and you would think companies go
out of business because engineering
screws it up the reality is in most
companies most markets 90 to 95% of the
failures are from a lack of customers
now for those of you engineers don't
feel smug because I've never seen a
product delivered on time but it's not
like the company goes out of business
because that goes out of business
because of this so I find it very
interesting that for the last 40 years
Silicon Valley has had tons of processes
to manage product development but no
processes to manage customer development
none and in fact the only thing we used
to have is this product introduction
model anybody ever see this before you
know you see ground you know product
development alpha test beta test first
customership anybody ever see this come
on yeah in fact that when I used to put
this up in my class students would say
yeah you know we've seen this and I used
to say yeah you know even the waiters in
San Francisco could draw this and some
of them used to say well we're waiters
because we used to be calm CEOs and I
said so that I'd never make that joke
again so I want but startups fail
because of this diagram this diagram
says and enhances and convinces founders
to make two major mistakes one is I know
what customers need and because I know
what customers need
I could spec the product on day one
right there now this is pretty
interesting because startups are an act
of faith right there are driven by the
passion of an entrepreneur and so part
of your passion has to be a belief that
you actually do know what problem to
solve so this is a real conundrum and
the way I describe it is that on day one
a start-up is a faith-based exercise
truly it's a passion but the ones the
startups that survive very quickly
replace that faith with facts as quickly
as possible and that is instead of
executing completely on faith well I
know it's my vision they go
I know it's my vision and I'm scared out
of my whatever that I might be wrong and
so here's the process to check it out
and that's what we're gonna talk about
but first I want to remind you how
startup used to work you draw this
diagram in your board meeting the board
would not sage really yes and then you'd
say well here's my marketing plan about
what what I was going to do in what
order I create mark on material hire PR
agency have a create demand have a
launch event you may not and here's how
I was gonna hire my sales VP I was gonna
hire a big big sales VP from a large
company I built the sales organization
time for first customership and then I
hired all the all-important bizdev first
and then a higher engineering from day
one maybe my co-founder and we'll do all
this stuff this is how you go out of
business I think it's pretty well
understood that what boards used to tell
you was yeah you got it good that's our
plan now actually is the leading cause
of death if it started why because you
really don't find out whether you're
right or wrong all the way onto your
burnt cash hired a ton of people and
launched the product so in contrast
here's how startup succeed they do
something called customer development
and this is where the founders get out
of the building customer development
says instead of this product
introduction model we're going to
replace it with something else we're
going to tell engineering to go do agile
development but we're gonna create a
process for managing fats and that's a
four-step process and that's called
customer development this first step
customer discovery get you out of the
building to test every hypothesis you
have customer validation ensures your
hypotheses are correct by actually
getting users or orders that validate
your solution customer creation is where
we scale the business and company
building is that stage which I had
labeled transition before remember where
you get to leave maybe you don't get to
leave anymore you get to stay and so
let's go through a bit of it customer
Dukas discovery says listen instead of
writing a business plan let's write down
all the hypotheses by the way I use the
word hypotheses because same I know what
current tuition is and GSB what's
current to tuition how much is it a year
50 grand okay if I were just to say test
your business model guesses you'd feel
cheated right but since you're paying 50
grand a year inside a business school I
use very expensive words
all right so you can tell your parents I
got my money's worth but if you really
think about what's going on in a startup
implicitly you unless you're a domain
expert another corner case unless you're
a domain expert as a founder you're
actually guessing you're guessing and
you're guessing about a lot of things or
maybe you're guessing about a set of
them but just small set but you're
guessing in customer discovery we're
gonna say guess what that's a normal
part of startups but we're gonna make
you write them down and get out of the
building and start discovering whether
they're true or not as quickly as
possible in a formal process and you're
not allowed to outsource this why well
what if in fact what if in fact you were
a founder you're a founder ready okay
got a great product your vision and you
hired a VP of Sales or early on and she
comes back and says what's your name
Nathan Nate Nathan all right Nathan
let's be formal here Nathan I'm here for
UPS Sales you know I got out early I'm
talking these customers you know what
they say the product sucks what are you
gonna tell me I'm your VP of Sales find
better customers great so she comes back
again after a month and you know I've
flown all around the US and about and I
had to say this they think it really
sucks now what do you say and maybe
there's a step in between that says
you're just not explaining it correctly
right or they just don't get it right
and then you do exactly what Nathan said
you fire the VP of Sales is it gonna get
any better
how come the CEO didn't say well maybe
that's true what's going on
what's going on why wouldn't you say
perhaps that's true why
why why would you have no effect think
you're scared some presence even worse
than ego by worse I mean you're so blind
to your investment and not on time money
but in the idea that there's a cognitive
dissonance that occurs and by the way
this is a big idea it will occur to
everyone of you in the CERN this is not
anybody being stupid this is human
nature at work here the only way to
break this chain is the founders need to
go out of the building so Nathan let's
we're gonna pick on you some more you're
now the CEO you're still the CEO you're
out of the building and I'm a customer
and you asked me what do you think of
the property
ask me it's us it still sucks make me
what do you do now you go to the next
customer cuz you go obviously an idiot
they're not deserving of my property
right now I rather than draw this out it
takes most people three times to hear it
before smoke starts coming out of their
own ears by the way it takes me usually
five or six times period but now I'm
gonna say most people will you know
figure you will never get it the first
time I'll guarantee you 99% of people
won't get it the second time he's kind
of the bell curve I was like on the
bleeding edge in fact what's worse is
the greater your reality distortion of
field personally the harder it is for
you to listen big idea by the way if
anybody's thinking about doing customer
development don't do it if it ain't you
or your co-founders getting out of the
building it can't be outsourced because
you will be hearing things that are
counter to your instincts beliefs and
whatever that you need to process and
eventually you will process them if
you're hearing them I will guarantee you
you will ignore them if rot - you second
and third-hand
that's why hiring consultants to go
do this etc consultants can make intros
for you and help you organize the
process but you personally need to be
hearing that data by the way yes yep
yeah go read the blog there's a ton of
it there time and there were lots of
people were writing about this now but
yes and in fact at the anvil I'll point
you to some researchers startup tools
and elites to the science tools on how
to fill no technically startup there's a
ton ton of fo links to other blogs that
talk about by the way our old friend the
business plan sometimes rears its head
here going well should I just be
executing off my plan I'm just gonna say
this one more time no business plan
survives first contact with custom
business plans come from large companies
they're great in large companies they're
great for professors who consult for
large companies in business schools
seriously no professor I will contend
who actually did a start-up can look at
you in the eye and tell you this is a
useful document and because we never had
anything to replace it with you know
there was no other contest to run but
I'll show you that we actually need to
be looking for this for a business model
as I said earlier you put four
professors in the room historically
you'd come up with nine definitions of
what a business model is because
everybody through that word around like
immense something now for the first time
I'm going to show you what it means
because this is the work of this other
book that I pointed out in the beginning
Alexander Osterwalder Osterwalder had a
great insight he said any company could
be described in nine building blocks and
I'll give you the cliff notes of the
book in a second he said listen first
building block is who are your customers
what are the what users are your serving
what jobs do they want to get done
what's your value proposition that
you're giving them that's a fancy word
for what product or service or you're
building how you getting it to them is
it the web direct sales force indirect
channel and how you're creating demand
what kind of customer relationships will
you have
and by the way to add all this stuff up
what's your revenue model
don't tell me free if it's free there
has to be in a two-sided market meaning
Oh
okay it's free and finish the sentence
and then we will make money by you know
whatever and it could be well we'll
figure it out later
alright well that's at least a
declaration of faith' it's not actually
a business model but we could at least
have that conversation on the other side
is what key resources do you need if
it's software a company you need great
engineers getting scarce are in Silicon
Valley it's a hardware company do you
need to go offshore what do you need to
do to perform it well is in
manufacturing is it something else do
you need any partners iTunes without the
record labels the iPod just would have
been another piece of hardware partners
and some businesses are essential and by
the way when you add up all the stuff on
the Left what's the cost structure nine
building blocks can describe any startup
now Osterwalder sting was a stroke of
genius and you can now take those and
put it into a canvas that is you know we
just took that fancy nice drawing and
said hey let's just make this a canvas
and now we'll take all our hypotheses
remember those hypotheses I talked about
your business is made up of a set of
hypotheses let's take the hypotheses
about your product whose your product
what's the market type what's your
competition about customers what problem
do you think they have who's the
customer who's the user who's the payer
who's the saboteur who's the influencer
what type of channel and you add all
these up and you can now use the
Osterwalder business model diagram to
actually become a scorecard for customer
discovery remember I said get out of the
building now you could actually say how
are we doing on this hey Wayman our
first assumption of who the customer is
oh that was wrong customer is actually
over here William and our pricing model
we thought it was a freemium business no
it should be a subscription business
boom we could change that just a nice
visual way to show us over time what
we're learning
the goal for engineering during this
time is to build what's called the
Minimum Viable Product Minimum Viable
Product is the smallest feature set that
gets you something and you get to define
what that something is this is the
minimum feature set that gets me orders
or is it the minimum feature set that
just gets me learning I want to put up
just a red button on my webpage to see
if I could get anybody to push it truly
that could be a Minimum Viable Product
for week one in a start-up can I create
demand to get people to this page or
could be no we're gonna I know what the
core features of our website should be
and are offering great do those or is it
to get feedback or is it to test some
failure modes the first two things you
need to be testing in that Osterwalder
diagram is the Minimum Viable Product
and who the customer is but remember
it's just one of those nine parts of
that business model and you're doing to
this customer discovery and validation
and again keeping score with the Oscar
Walter diagram now there's an arrow on
the bottom called the pivot this is
actually the heart of customer
development and it's actually what we
got wrong for the last 40 years of
startups remember I kept saying startups
are not smaller versions of large
companies well we never acted like that
and here's an example why cuz any of
you've been in a start we're gonna
recognize a scenario startup goes
through a first cup goes through a
launch first customership
has a great board meeting everybody's
high-fiving each other cuz TechCrunch
wrote about your company you know people
are hitting the website things are
wonderful next board meeting board s VP
of Sales how's the number referring to
the revenue plan VP of Sales says all of
that sales pipeline is great well what
does that mean a website it could be
well we got lots of clicks but didn't
quite converter and a direct sales could
be hey know we got lots of people to
talk to us but we're not quite getting
any orders next board meeting how we do
it VPS else goes pipeline
next board meeting how are we doing
pipeline and by the way the next board
meeting the V the VCS unbeknownst to you
go to school to learn how to their
heads at a 15 degree angle and arch one
eyebrow I mean it's like just amazing
because they do it
synchronous or you know like just
instant whatever that word is but just
all together at the same time and they
stare at the CEO really revenue plan no
the next board meeting you open the door
and I don't know how they do it but
there's a flaming sword of death over
the VP of Sales and no one is sitting
next to her I mean all the chairs are in
one side of the room and she's like dad
knows that the wrong thing to say is pop
you just and you shut the door very
quickly because you open it again and
she's gone it's just amazing it's like a
magic trick happens all the time and by
the way next board meeting you open the
door again and there's someone else just
looks like her but it was a guy you know
like what happened we got a new VP of
Sales now the interesting part here some
of you might recognize this story is
that the new VP of Sales unless that guy
and the CEO are complete idiots does not
execute the same sales strategies the
last one they go gee that was stupid
them it was just because they were
idiots we're gonna do another strategy
what happens if that new strategy
doesn't work well gets fired next
no.not CEO must be a marketing problem
none of your laughing but has to be a
marketing problem yeah and then we fire
the CEO what did I just describe here
what I just described is a some of you
might recognize the normal path on how
we solve problems in a start-up and no
one in 40 years recognized wait a minute
this occurs more often than the case
that we actually execute the plan
pristinely in fact in almost every
startup it doesn't occur or doesn't roll
out per the plan
this is a huge idea startups are all
about chaos and things not working like
you believe your hypotheses are almost
always wrong in a startup that is
they're not often right yet the way we
used to deal with this is by firing
executives to iterate the strategy whoa
what a waste in time and money this
feedback loop the pivot simply says
being wrong is a normal part of the
startup getting your hypotheses wrong is
normal so what we're gonna do is instead
of firing people we're gonna say you
know we got something wrong in our
discovery process we just misheard what
the market said because we thought they
said if we deliver tax they pay why
didn't work that way okay
we didn't hire 15 people in a sales
force we haven't hired you know 400
other people in support
let's just go iterate that's what the
pivots for makes sense now so wrap up
syrups are not small versions of large
companies traditional big company
planning tools fail and stirrups are
built on hypotheses you need to test
each one of them business models help
you keep score customer development is
the process to test the hypotheses now I
got about 11 more minutes can I tell you
one short more short story sure anybody
wants to leave you can but there's one
more stir story so why startups aren't
run by accountants they might an
accountant here I don't want to like
completely you could leave now
anyway know who the inventor of the
modern corporation is look at this guy
doesn't he look serious this actually is
a real Time magazine article from 1920s
cover you might know who he is who was
he
yeah I'm glad you could read who was it
what about General Motors who was he ran
good ran okay anybody else Alfred P
Sloan General Motors president and
chairman he actually invented the cost
accounting system for running large
corporation corporations of the 20th
century are basically possible because
this guy took the accounting system that
DuPont used in World War one who was on
his board
as you'll hear later and actually
applied it to making GM into a large
distributed organization put the
managerial financial controls and it was
copied by every other major corporation
in the United States pre-world war ii
and post-world war ii led to the
american century in terms of corporate
expansion overseas truly a genius lots
of things are named after MIT Sloan
School sloan foundation Sloan Kettering
Cancer Institute in New York everybody
know who Kettering was oh another fact
he was his VP of engineering of course
so great guy and in some classes I get
people say why yes he was the founder of
GM
turns out slow and had nothing to do
with founding of GM by 20 years this guy
was the founder doesn't look like a
founder come on which guy would you
rather hang out with this guy this guy
this guy we could take him this picture
two streets of Palo Alto one night yeah
come on go down the bars this was Billy
Durant Billy Durant was the founder of
General Motors Billy Durant also was the
leader in the United States and
horse-drawn buggies in the 1890s out of
Flint Michigan built the largest
horse-drawn buggy
company in the US one day Billy Durant
sitting in the bar was in the bar in
Flint with his fellow bug
manufactures probably Friday afternoon
not gonna couple back and all of a
sudden they hear this noise coming up
this dirt covered street it was like the
loudest thing they'd ever heard and all
of a sudden they see this carriage
coming it was it wasn't even one of
Durant's it was one of his competitors
and it didn't have any horses and
somebody had strapped a one cylinder
engine to it 1890s and basically you
know called the transportation and the
rest of his friends were hysterical
because this thing looked like it was
gonna catch fire anytime horses were
running wild you know and they were all
look at that Durant's sobered up in
about 30 seconds next Monday he sold his
entire business gal the buggy business
and started buying up technology
companies at the time highest tech
companies in the 1890s automobile
companies it was not a technologist but
this guy was an entrepreneur and Billy
Durant bought up a series of car
companies and starts a company called
General Motors builds it into the
largest automobile company in the United
States in 1910 and then as fired by his
board because he's a crazy entrepreneur
insane careless reckless etc but he's
also pissed he's so angry at his board
for firing them
he says screw you guys finds another
entrepreneur and starts another car
company called Chevrolet built Chevrolet
into a bigger brand and company than
General Motors takes it public and buys
out all the GM stock fires his board and
takes over his company again
remember a guy named Steve Jobs runs his
company for another 10 years to 1921 GM
is 3.6 billion dollars in today's
dollars being run by his founder and he
again screws up financially this time
he's gambling with the company stock
I mean clearly crazy entrepreneur and
this time the finance peers he has on
the board aren't some local yokels it is
the DuPont's and they fire for the
second time Durant gets fired from
General Motors 1921 company's three
point six billion dollars Durant vs.
Sloan Sloan becomes the icon of American
management rightly so in the 1920s to
the 1950s the American Century truly is
the GM century he dies rich honored and
famous Durant he dies penniless managing
a bowling alley in 1947 he was the
accountant you are here thank you very
much
so I got time if anybody has any
questions what I said but change the
interaction at the board mean from day
one so I'm writing a handbook for VCS
and startup CEOs about what we should
really be talking about here's what you
ought to be asking your startup here's
what you ought to be reporting to your
board very different but but the
problems we haven't had that handbook
and one of the other jokes I have with
my VC friends as they say Steve if we
were creative we'd have your job you
make up the damn list then I realize
okay I'm gonna have to do that so that's
my project for the next year and did
that resonate by the way for yeah but
you know what if it's amen and we now
get it how come we're still doing the
same old thing
right yes his customer development a
skill set typically we're seeing as
parasites where your to Paris I'm
getting two engineers to start the
company services so so typically you're
the company's right man overseas
excess baggage or we're seen as being
valuable once you have work you polish
their business model and as an NBA was
not a technologist is is is is
familiarity with the custom development
model and the process a valuable skill
that you can bring to a foundation so
Christophe is a valuable skill I mean I
own an issue decrees and customer
development the insight that all the
classes you've learned about execution
in large companies our excess baggage is
the biggest asset you could take out of
this for your entire NBA career the
skillet I'm sorry I really don't
remember
somebody else did refrigerator but my
point is it's not that they're MBA is
useless and and I don't want to make
that case at all an MBA is one of the
most valuable things you could have
remember corporations were around for
hundreds of years before harbors did the
first Masters of Business Administration
in 1908 Perry we traced the Martin
corporation to the formation of the East
India Company in 1600 right 300 years
before we issued an MBA do you think
companies weren't running until somebody
says you need an MBA Masters of Business
Administration was an observation is
that we can now professionalize all the
execution things we need to happen I'll
observe that in the next ten years we
will realize that we have now
accumulated enough knowledge to create a
parallel track to be schools which I'll
just call a school which is customer
development agile development business
model design user centric design
entrepreneurial finance those are the
skill sets that if I were to train you
and give you a curriculum you can
acquire that knowledge here at Stanford
you just have to pick and choose if you
want to add value to an early-stage
startup I will just again extremely
claim that the large companies skills
you learn are detrimental bringing him
in the first year they are wonderful
when the company gets to the transition
you're the guy they need but if you want
to play in the early days you need to be
able to be a you know football player
and ballerina at the same time does that
yet so so it's unlikely that an MBA is
going to become a rails or Django
developer but if we have to make a
decision does it make sense become
extremely well-versed in the practice of
customer demand
Ashleigh so so you're going down a path
I just want to take an aside because
this is real
the opposition for me the rest of you
could go if you want to but the
interesting conversation every year
because I teach in the business school
at Berkeley and Columbia every year I
get at least one or two students going
professor blank I need some help we got
I got a sort of job choices too to sort
through great what's your choice oh it's
just offered a job by McKinsey well
great McKinsey is a great company what's
your other choice oh my roommates are
thinking of doing a startup and I go
well you already decided and they always
say well we mean you didn't hear my risk
I said you already decided a startup is
not an effing job a startup is a passion
nowadays it happens to be hip and cool
to do but a startup is not a job you
don't want to take a job in a start-up
trust me you don't because you will fail
you want to be passionate and this thing
has to be something you can't get out of
your head and if and if it's not don't
go near it for the first year or two but
I'm not talking it has to be that way
forever but if you want to be the first
ten people or 20 people in an
early-stage venture it is not a job
choice am i making and I'm not saying
that that's what you're doing but truly
it has to be
I can't wait a boy this is exciting and
if that's the case then the question is
what skills do I need to bring right and
yes your MBA analytical business skills
could be immensely helpful if you
understand their differences in an
early-stage venture from an execution
venture all right anybody else yes
yes yes so Apple Oracle Amazon etc are
one of these it took me a deputy of
there explain those because they were
main novels if you look at that many go
hey cairo doesn't work and every time
someone would say that I'd say let's
have Bill Gates and then change this up
so really what's going on in Apple is
just an amazing example that I think
proves the rule
first of all does anybody believe that
Steve Jobs truly sits in a locked room
and like you know zen-like comes up with
a new set of features without ever
talking to anybody
I mean that's what your PR people they
need a PR people from Apple want you to
believe and I used to believe that too
cuz how can this guy if that's true how
come you know how did this work just
broke every law of physics until there's
been a hint that no one's picked up they
may know that Steve Jobs at least when
he was healthy used to answer customers
email at least once or twice a month
anybody ever read those stories on the
Apple great jobs it's a little hint do
you think he's just reading those two
emails he's responding to jobs is
reading every damn email he gets and I
knew his VP of engineering jobs wanted
to know every technology innovation
going on in every peripheral company in
the world anybody ever seen jobs in the
Palo Alto Apple store all the time this
guy he didn't need to go there to buy a
computer you think they would have
delivery one to was out right this guy
is more attuned and what he did and it's
a model for what these guys who survived
the founders they hired world-class
operators that is their number twos are
with all due respect to Jonathan Ive and
and Phil Schiller and all these things
are not Steve Jobs they are world class
executors executors jobs is sitting up
here moving the chess pieces
he hired world-class people to execute
that would have been world class
anywhere but without him and my
prediction Apple over time will turn
into a another large company
just like Microsoft and I forgotten what
your question was
yeah so so there are there are
individuals who managed to hire world
class people but still keep the
entrepreneurial DNA and that's what him
and five or ten other leaving a Reed
Hastings and Netflix same thing thing
Reed is still running the entire company
know he hired world-class people to
manage underneath them but he's kept
hold and not let go of the product
vision strategy that's what's consistent
across all those innovative startups
they're now large companies make sense
last question
[Music]
anytime one of those boxes substantively
skip this pivot it's any time you change
something minor wait the color or price
you know price instead of pricing model
price that's an iteration start up
through multiple pivots and multiple
iterations and if you want to see some
great examples of it I teach a class
here at Stanford called engineering 245
we have students from the BT school and
the engineering school work together to
not only build the company but get
orders in ten weeks their presentations
are online they're now doing their final
presentations it's at e 245 just look it
up at Stanford you could find the entire
class online and you will see students
doing this in 10 weeks question
what do they what was u.s. car
manufacturers riding up to visit
Japanese nineteen seventies and eighties
they went into the Japanese car plants
not understanding anything about agile
they looked at the manufacturing lines
and you know what they saw what do they
see
nope that's Japan what they see no
robots lots of robots u.s. car
manufacturers particularly GM came home
and said we got it we know the secret of
Japanese manufacturing robots next 10
years they ordered 87 billion dollars of
robots from